hello and welcome to another
night of chess and psychology we have
few
person audience so hopefully
there will be a fun balance between my
in person and my life wait
my online
audience
so
i was struggling to figure out which
ironian to show because i have two super
cool ironian games one of them
uh he's the one
looking a little um
unhappy in the end and the other one
magnus is the one that's looking unhappy
i feel like our onion beating magnus is
something that we kind of see more often
that are only losing to like a
less
super gm type of person
so
i decided to go with that one and
another special thanks because this game
is again in the book that's upcoming
that i did with my brother and he was
responsible for most of this game's
analysis as well i feel like i'm just
using his analysis instead of my own at
this point
um
so yeah especially according to borno so
yeah we got that going
and um
in this game
yeah uh i think borna because borna is
playing for uk chess federation so he
likes the uk youngsters
i guess like quote unquote youngsters
and i think luke mccain is one of the
persons one of the people who my brother
borna kind of looks up to and because
he's like 2700 and he's been playing
with the high level chess for a while as
well actually fun thing uh wait i don't
know if i'm supposed to say this um i'll
just give it a vague description my
brother was invited to play with one of
the
very interesting upcoming september
tournaments for uk
um in the world
like with jones and everybody else and
so he was kind of happy about that so
yeah
maybe i should have shown one of his
games anyways he can play good games in
september and we'll show those all right
let's get going before i keep talking
about it
so
yeah this was a very fun game that levon
got kind of crushed by mcshane
and um
yeah so the opening is um
quite interesting because
hold on let me actually disable the
sound on this there we go yeah because i
am a family that got disabled jesus
christ there we go
i am a fan of
uh sloth but i
i've played this very little like
i have played nimzo indian kings indiana
queens in the end like all these
different
ways to kind of not play slav frequently
i've played it
very few games like i'm familiar with
the structure i'm familiar with the um
well what's going on in the game and
especially in the middle game section
but i don't feel like
um i don't feel like i get a calling
from slav if that makes sense same with
a lot of the sicilians as black i found
a small calling from naidor if i played
it oh my god those games are horrible so
i think that was a
miss style from najdorf to me
anyways um i did however try like some
of these a6 ideas without c6
it was a weird game i prepared a lot for
it i was playing it in some tournament
in italy and i had a good game but i
miscalculated them
yes that didn't really go my way but
these a6 uh here or later or like in
different lines are kind of
i've realized that they're very useful
in um
d4d5 lines so if you are interested in
making your opponent a little
unbalanced i think that would be kind of
fun
well going backwards sorry yeah
um
all right
so we have reached a
position that i would like to question
people unfortunately my live audience
can kind of see the um the answers sorry
yeah but that's okay um i kind of want
my own little cheat sheet so i can't
really
i mean
yeah i wish i could somehow like just
choose what to show but
okay
oh my god
that's okay hold your hand up today
put the little tape oh actually we could
put a little tape there all right uh
time for creativity is later yeah so um
yeah i thought it would be an
interesting
um
way to yeah cause usually in the
openings i like to take like a moment to
get everybody to consider well what's
going on in the position what does white
want was black one so on that spear i
thought i would be a good idea to
question you guys now
so i'll give it just a minute because
i'm already getting some answer from
chad's like a bishop of five which is
very interesting
greeting from brazil i was in brazil
2011. i loved it
there was a very fun like green soda
thingy that i really liked that i cannot
find anywhere else
2011.
isn't the bishop to f5 more than risky
i mean so the reason i'm pausing here is
because you kind of have to make a
decision on where like what do you want
to do with the tension here are you
going to take it right now are you going
to take it later so
a lot of the times the deciding on what
type of punch structure you want to
enter is a very big part of the opening
i'm sure that the players here because
they're grandmasters and actually super
grandmasters who have do do know this
opening but i'm kind of trying to um
like step back and look at a bigger
picture rather than if we didn't know
this opening then how would we choose
our middle game or how to choose our
piece placement so that's what we're
trying to do and somebody asked about
talia's cooking i mean she's joining
slough so i'm gonna get her to you know
show me some tricks but i don't know if
we're gonna do a cooking stream
we did that on the countdown it's
nothing oh
that's what they're afraid oh i think
when you tell it to do another cook show
okay
yeah
anyways uh oh my god i'm getting some
cool bishop five knight d4s all right
thank you thank you you know these are
these are very interesting
ideas um
what else
does anybody want to actually take it
over here
to be fair e3 is usually more considered
to be
quote
safe for the bishop because with e3
you're like focusing more on the other
bishops especially on slav
but um bishop jeff there's like there's
nothing wrong with the bishop on g5 but
we should most likely
consider more options
hello kion
all right yeah so i actually it's kind
of fun nobody wants to take it
yeah everybody likes to keep the
attention and i like i feel like my
people here are not very inclined to
take two but
well
they took it uh
um
ah
probably more towards the end
yeah
thank you though so yeah i think taking
is a very fun way to
figure out a small imbalance in the
position because like again
right now this could also be
the type of preparation that people
would do like
taking on c4 might not be your usual
move but when you're trying to
um kind of trick the opponent's opening
or you're trying to do like the cool
preparations these are the ways to look
into it so knight e4 is something that i
saw mentioned in the chat and i it's
also worth mentioning the issue with it
is that
you're not going to take it because take
take then this line is kind of um up in
the air the problem is you just play
bishop f4 now you have this really nice
diagonal you have really nice diagonal
and if take take you're just going to
simply bring your bishop out from uh
this side
and it's
a little
unclear how black is going to continue
because white has a lot of options to
contrib contributes more to the position
and white definitely does have enough
compensation for that one pawn pieces
are more activated there's more space
there's there's more center for white so
not necessarily the most intriguing
option to play knight e4
so that's why taking is
in my understanding that was home prep
anyways a4
if e4 possible but we do have b5 so this
is like a whole different
line of um
analysis and theory and oh boy yeah but
definitely worth considering if you are
going to take it you always have to be
ready for white grabbing center and
you're pushing um i've done my fair
share of um
unhappy pawn eatings in catalan when you
can eat that and then you can push b5 so
you always have to be careful because
then you're going to be spending so many
so many moves protecting the pawn and
sometimes it might not be worth it
anyhoo right now ironian went a4 to kind
of prevent this a b5 and
this is the move that was quite crucial
h6
because we're trying to kind of see are
you gonna are you gonna you know move
away from this pin are you gonna take it
we're gonna kind of question it why is
that bishop on g5 what are you trying to
do with it
so our onion went to h4 the thing is if
he takes it over here
take back kaboom to stop b5s and now
this is going to be a good game for
black black has enough space black has
an extra pawn white doesn't have that's
like awesome of a center so definitely
something that um
might not be the best choice for whites
and that's kind of the question that
maxine is asking ironian are you here to
eat my knight because if you are then
i'm going to have enough active active
pieces to
fight back so bishop iv was played and
now what do we do so i'm going to take
another small pause to get you guys on
the same page
and while you're thinking about it i'm
probably gonna tell you a tiny story
regarding his majesty the cat
so yeah
we did go to chicago as i was mentioning
last week we went to chicago over the
weekend he was such a good boy in the
trip his cat's
cat backpack came he was such a good boy
and
yeah he enjoyed his travels as i'm i
think he's being shown to you oh yeah
the kitty um
oh yeah
uh yeah he was such a good boy enjoyed
it he wasn't he was a blast in the train
he was just amazing
oh no deep dish pizza i feel like i
would need like six other people to help
me finish that pizza if i could just get
a slice i would but if i feel like if i
eat a whole pizza
i don't think that would go well for my
digestive system
but gmpg exactly exactly he spent
most of morning in vets to get his
international health certificate so we
can fly to london oh goodness so yeah
that's a whole different process but
i thought it would be fair to show his
majesty the cats or i guess gmp she
anyways
so now hopefully you guys are slightly
more inspired to
find the better moves here
okay um
thank you thank you yeah
that's a cute little backpack
yeah so
now that's the thing like e4 is coming
up
and we should be aware of the fact that
this pawn on a4 also wants to jump to a5
so we can never ever play b5 so
the main
thing that you have to consider right
now is do i ever want to play b5 because
if you ever want to play b5 it's now or
never
white does want to play pawn to a5 next
move and then you're never going to be
able to play b5 well actually you could
legally but that's going to be very ugly
so if you want a pretty b5
it's now or never
so with that information and with the
cat positivity uh should we play b5 now
or
still waiting
i would rather develop pieces
at this point
okay so
let me let me try to ask you a question
what why would you do what what is the
purpose of developing pieces
fair point
that's i can't argue with that yet
but um the other way to look at it is
that when we develop pieces so we can
gain space and we can take scores away
from the opponent so if opponent has
this one move that will continuously
bother us for the remainder of the game
and we'll take we'll make him
psychologically happy as well and will
make us always question like i wish i
could play b5 now is this worth it for
to wonder the whole game should have
should have i stopped this should i
because i get it developing is always
good but would b5 be a kind of
development because we're taking space
and we're making opponents not as happy
with a5
yes you are correct about the tactical
aspect of it yeah
so b5 take take knight takes yes
now the other part is
are we going to take it because if we
take the rook takes rook and um we have
a very interesting pond two pawns over
here
and we have a very nice open diagonal
let me get the bishop here but is it
worth it
yeah
sorry it is indeed unbalanced but
oh my goodness
um
but
and i agree this might be too hard to
figure it out over the board if you've
never seen stuff like this if you
haven't prepared this
but um
yeah i can i can guess that mcshane had
at least prepared it or he was least of
all you know somewhat prepared for this
position if not specifically for this
opponent he knew what he was doing
so
do we want to give up the exchange
point yeah
oh question is queen d3 okay i mean
i would eat it
i'm always going to if you watched me
queen b3 again i will eat it don't worry
d orbee as long as oh my maybe you're oh
i mentioned queen b6 i guess
um
i mean your pawns kind of got ugly and
this one is a lonely one so i'm not
going to
no i don't really like it no
no no it's okay so
yeah the squares would be
not that easy yeah so um
if you were if you played b5 you kind of
have to be ready for that sacrifice you
can't just play b5 and be like
like best of luck or like i'm gonna you
know what is it like i'm gonna wish for
the best wishing for the best does not
work
luck luck is a huge component of success
but you also have to put in the effort
so queen b6 does not work but it's
understandable why you would want it to
okay so it's a ginormous sacrifice rook
is going to go back to a1
now what if rick went to a7 let's try to
look into this a little bit too
this bishop is gorgeous over here yeah
we do have we should have enough
compensation we shouldn't have to worry
about
um the the the material imbalance
okay now actually queen b6 works thank
you yeah queen b6 kaboom boom
and now you would simply just develop
and then get this bishop out
and slowly slowly castle black is a
little bit more comfortable but because
you know this pawn is more advanced this
bishop is kind of
slightly misplaced but um
white is kind of pressure but it's still
quite a
playable game for both sides
however rook just going back to a1 it's
kind of like a
even psychologically you just eat
something you get attacked you go back
to where you came from it's not it's not
necessarily the most um
aggressive way he is not showing like
power it's not showing the dominance
that you would want to show over the
chessboard exactly now the queen side is
looking kind of nice for black
so
okay so we got it done the queen side is
looking nice how about the king side or
the center how can black gain more
stuff in queenside uh queensland is good
attacking black and some stuff in the
king side or in the center
i guess there's some oomph
i've recently came across this
word
still not sure how to use it so
oh there's a good question what's the
difference between
good advanced pawns like these and
overextended ones
i mean
as long as the pot like there's a pawn
chain rather than a solo pawn
i would like that if it's a solo pawn
it's just a target practice for
opponents but these are kind of
protected
so kion i think that's the general idea
but
let's i want us to be more opportunistic
exactly yeah we can't just do chill
stuff we gotta probably be a little bit
more aggressive
isn't b5 a weakness who's attacking it
b2 could be a weakness to it nobody's
attacking is because mobile is attacking
it's right now it's okay
but yes it has the potential for
becoming a weak
link
yeah good idea
so i have a live audience g5
recommendation how does the chat feel i
kind of also want to check on my phone
because i actually don't see myself here
i don't know how the
setup is feeling
oh good good
still kind of
i'm gonna make a quick look
i don't think i don't think i have to oh
my god well um
did anybody here enjoy the evil laughter
button that i created on the twitch
stream
today yeah like right before this i was
playing viewers and i was like you know
what i want an evil after button so i'm
going to youtube it
yeah that was that was actually fun
potential um copyright
today
definitely i
i got some good clips out of it thank
you
okay perfect
yeah g5 i mean i see the chat is kind of
warming up to the g5 idea as well
good good
thank you
yeah uh g5 is a good idea oh yeah it
does
yeah g5 does look like a good idea
especially because after g5 you um
you're again questioning this what
you're gonna do are you gonna be cuckoo
bananas and sacrifice stuff over here
let me say blunder stuff over here or
are you going to be a good little boy
and go back it's kind of like you know a
little
asserting dominance over the chess board
too and this is
psychologically huge thing i knew of
these players um i yeah like even young
players who like
psychologically like they were like you
know when you're playing over the board
you're like you know come over the board
like squeeze your head or stare into
opponents or either do like stuff like
that that shows dominance
and the the body language yeah
yeah exactly we're kind of showing this
bishop who's the boss
and little by little it kind of
accumulates so
i'm not necessarily telling you to start
kicking your opponent under the table
but but a little
you know devil eyes doesn't hurt anybody
okay
so i like this g5 and so if we wanted to
play chill and play something like h6
now take take like oh sorry if takes
then we would still have this um
nice two bishops nice diagonal this
would still be kind of nice right but
what if white also chose to develop
now if you try to be cute about it
i feel like black is still fine but
we we we don't have that that space in
the king side in the king side we're
still kind of like
questioning it ah what should i do with
the knight i wish i could move this
knight this is still okay if you want to
play e6 that's fine but g5 is just um
again dominance
all right bishop goes back now we just
do e6
now we're gonna bring this guy over here
hi brian all right
um now we're gonna check this guy
king up and to be fair night these twos
are horrible
does anybody want to tell me why
knight to e4 exactly yeah this is a
yep
yep yep
yeah exactly free night
it's a nice little pin
good luck yep
so you kind of got to move up the king
oh i mean i i think the problem is first
like you kind of yeah you kind of uh
give up on some slippery room
we all know how i feel about slippery
stuff
yeah
there we go
okay yeah this is much easier just clean
cut
wait i've been showing you i've been
watching too many um
weird murder tv shows i should probably
stop that clean cut
whoa okay
i just finished watching lucifer
it's about like the devil and gods and
stuff
cool
oh my god okay
kind of went a whole different direction
now
okay black to move what do we do
we still have a bunch of pieces to get
out
yeah we were talking about this on
twitch channel a little while ago like
um like netflix um
ideas and i was like
i have not watched that much netflix
recently
but i was talking about my favorite
shows and i was like oh yeah dexter was
fun how to get to get away with murder
was fun i was like wait these are
not very
friendly tv shows
yeah
oh my god yeah
no they're kind of fun but
if you like too much of it could
mess with your head
anywho
before establishing how to get away with
murder let's talk about how to check my
taranium that's next step
exactly but let's first learn how to get
away with murder on chessboard for next
month we can upgrade it to premium
lessons
oh my god
yeah
that's simon you were gone for two
minutes and just got a whole lot of
hands oh no
oh yeah
all right um
yeah i don't know about my t4 i feel
like we still got this guy to develop
it's like we still got this guy to put
in a safe spot we still have to put the
queen in some
um
more useful spot so i don't necessarily
want to neces you know rush into knight
e4
i don't think knight d5 is a bad idea
but
too too early
what about your shift to e4
i feel like that's still the same thing
it's too early because even if you were
to play bishop before now
i mean it's a cute idea don't get me
wrong i mean it's good work but
ironian might see the the the checkmate
potential
yeah and try to stop it
could be very fun for bullets though
don't get me wrong
yeah
so
okay i i think you have a nice idea
about wanting to activate your bishop
well maybe first let's activate the
knight and then we can move on to the
bishop
ah stop showing i can't stop it sorry
all right so
maybe one more minute for the chat i see
a lot of people are loving knight e4
knight e4 is something that we are like
we want to do well we need more
preparation we can't just you know go
around and bounce around our knights we
need to be prepared
exactly 94 is cute
but
we need more
is everything the knight c6
knight two a5 knight to b3 oh fantasy i
kind of actually like this
i can live with this yeah knight c6 is a
good idea yeah
and we're gonna go jump to b3 and um
yeah this is not necessarily going in
the same direction as getting the bishop
to d3 but that knight on b3 is
questioning the rook again now we're
gonna go with the rook let's say if you
get your knight to b3 this rook
is
in a deep trouble because you can't go
to c1 you can't come to a3 a4 a5 or a6
the only places that the rook would have
to go
are these three and
they're not very useful squares so
actually b1 is out because bishop can go
to e4 and jump to d3
so not b1 if we could get that knight to
b3 that would be very interesting
so
there we go so uh our onion is trying to
fight back arnold doesn't want this
knight to get to b3 but he doesn't
really have that much option
um
right now some ideas with knights d5
while it might have been more
interesting
short castle could have been also
interesting but i think knight a5 is
just good enough you don't need to
always do the perfect move when you have
the more practical move handies on id5
practical enough we like it uh ironian
made it in a small inaccuracy with
bishop e5 so knight c2 would have made
more sense because now you're attacking
this guy and knight b3 doesn't work
because you know i'll just eat your
bishop right
so then you would have to move this
bishop and you would probably have to go
back and now i can start to try to grab
some of the center and try to put my
king in a safe spot i would have much
more uh options rather than just being a
sitting duck ah finally i learned how to
use that expression
yeah because that does not translate
well in far c so it's always like what
but anyways this is a this is the
definition of sitting duck if you don't
do these
i guess that's a running duck
okay
yeah so um knight c2 would have been a
better choice and another way to
consider it is uh momentum i don't know
if that's a word that's the familiar in
everyday
uh english language but the concept of
momentum is very very very interesting
in chess that's one of the reasons like
you always want to be attacking
something you always want to have some
sort of plan handy you always like it's
that like little
not playing so chill of like oh i want
to play like king h1 and king ji won you
know like not are you mean initiative
i've always learned it as momentum i
referred to this momentum but i'm
assuming initiative could be the same
thing but i feel like initiative is when
you start something or like you know
yeah yeah but momentum is more like
you're like using that moment
i think
again please do feel free to go yeah
gaining tempo yeah temple do feel free
to correct me because some some stuff
could get lost in translation from farsi
to english
so yeah night city would have been
pretty cool but i don't actually know
why arne messed it up i guess he'll be
here in like what two three days i can
bring him over to stream and ask him hey
why did you mess this up i don't think
i'm going i'm ever going to do that
i have way too much respect for him too
go and just talk to him like a bro but
anyways
yeah nice you too not the best choice i
might actually yeah
uh we can send him a letter
subtle
here
yeah okay
nice to do would be kind of cool but he
missed it
he went with bishop e5
see i feel like he's like on the same
spot he wants to activate his pieces he
wants to gain space momentum blah blah
but
not didn't he kind of miss
maybe he
underestimated the power of this knight
over here
which is unlikely so i don't know i
don't know i don't want to say um how he
was thinking but anyways knight c2 would
have been better than bishop e5 but he
went from bishop b5 first and then he
kind of continued h4 he took a whole
different direction
anyways
bishop f6 is also worth mentioning but
we could simply take back and now if you
do knight c2
we can simply bring knight c6
yeah right thank you exactly if you take
now i will just simply take back now
this is mine oh
fruit fly
get out of here
i
spies wait all right this pie is insects
truly
see that's the thing he would i don't
know
he never gets fruitful eyes or
mosquitoes he likes bigger he'll exactly
fly flies he kind of just
whips them off the air
i do have a nice bug spray for
mosquitoes and fruit flies
anyways
um
yeah this would have been a very
interesting turn of events
anyhoo let me go back
knight c2 still would have been an
interesting way to follow then maybe h4
but
i guess that kind of transposed anyways
with h4 first and then knight c2 so
kind of same thing but black is already
comfortable in this position black has
already established the dominance oops
black has already established that this
knight is going to
be a pain in
well your existence
yeah
so um
yeah good luck with this night basically
uh so irony is still trying to find a
safe spot for the king
but kaboom
now there is this there's a uh this is a
fine move but there was even a better
move so
what do you guys think black to move
what do you think
annoys white the most
if you've moved from chess and
psychology to how to annoy your opponent
the most
actually i like that title more than
just on psychology
i feel like that is
the theme
yeah basically but i think just a
psychology has a more um
how to say neutral
drink to it then
yeah
yeah that could be what it's called on
the surface
right
oh buff can i'm glad for you you love
chess
good
we too so that's why we're all here
they should be four maybe but that's not
you know it's not
all right so let's take a step back
this king moving back
how does it change white's position
what's different now
what piece from black is under attack
what ideas does white have that they
didn't stress to move ago
true it does free the bishop what else
is it free
free up
hello
yeah yeah
yeah exactly this is now a problem
so yeah and he might want to take it and
take it over here you might want to play
h5 to just
yeah so if this is a weakness and if
there are some evil ideas with h5 well
you know what let's take that away from
opponent if if h5 makes you happy you
ain't getting it
basically that should be your chest it
should be a high thinking chest oh my
god
i don't have no kids are watching this
anyways yes h5 is the way to go because
your opponent wants h5 your point lost
your pawn on g4 uh-huh
all right so then you could you know um
now white is really in deep trouble
because you can't exactly move this
bishop you can't develop it you're kind
of stuck here with the rock if you were
to move the bishop boom wait actually
first this boom and then the other boom
yeah looks like something in the queen
side something in the king side and i
feel like i want my evil laughter button
now but
okay
all right yeah so and then uh all you
have to do is not mess it up with
something like bishop e4 because each
bishop e4 it would be a
sad mistake of take
take
and
take
yeah
so uh let me let me actually show you
why this isn't
why this is a mistake
come back here's h5 and now white is
getting the initiative the momentum the
whole shipping
so we don't want that so we should if
white wants stuffed on g4 i am simply
going to tell you uh bishop h3
might look momentarily ugly but this
bishop is serving his purpose of keeping
this rook miserable it just ate a pawn
and it's saving this pawn so overall
this bishop is looking
pretty good
anyways
um let's go back so i was just showing
you how h5 would have been pretty
and
slightly suffocating for white
so
black said to go with a slightly
different move order
now white instead of rookie 2 could have
chosen to take over here take kaboom
check come back boom rook h3k7 black is
still slightly better but this gives
white more chance of fighting and
um
right that kind of giving you a little
better
uh
idea of how
white can now be annoying
you know the rook on sevens rank this
queen just ate upon
oh yeah sitting duck thank you
that was a finglish type of
massages class so yeah this is this is a
this would be a problem intermediate
moves
or k2 now we get h5 so now this is good
enough i can live with this bishop e2
and bishop g2 is still looking
interesting
but we don't have to do it we could
definitely this could be the same thing
as last the the line that i just showed
but we don't necessarily have to we can
simply go bishop d6 this bishop is
literally the only white piece that's
actually active so let's get rid of it
all right now black turmoil what should
we do
and ravi is saying good morning
oh my god where are you
where would be morning now
like morning morning not middle of the
night morning asia
fair point
because i know a lot of countries right
now like between like 3am 4am 5am i
guess 5am is morning
i've been trying to uh wake up like
around six for the last few days and i
feel like i get just so tired
after like 12 13 hours my eyes start to
go
wobbly
i'm finally making waking up around 8 8
30 i think that's the normal time that
i'm like yeah that's like my
no like i could do that
that's six seven ouch
oh five am you better be getting some
coffee man all right so what should we
do here as black
any suggestions
okay 95 definitely interesting
what else do we have
and uh nj fan uh me too i remember the
nights that i was just like watching the
movie or something and sun would come up
and like ah this again
yep
so
bishop takes bishop opens up the center
with the king stolen castle
interesting so you're suggesting
potential take
take back and knight d5 i can actually
yeah i think i'll be happy with this
this is a problem this knight here is
just
like that's the only thing that's
defending a bunch of things
um
king cat castle
not legally at least if this was a blitz
game somebody might forget
oh my god
i'm bored
oh yeah this one is coming too yep
exactly if you try to just bring up the
king then boom yeah you are probably
this is this would be quite interesting
uh in the game next changes under 95
this is good enough but bishop takes e5
was a better idea
now take okay now what do we do
oh ravi india is a beautiful country i
was there two times 2009
and 2014.
oh my god i'm getting old
i was real i realized i've done most of
my traveling in my youth like in my
actually not used in my baby stage
now that i'm getting
an age that you would actually enjoy the
traveling
or just sitting home and studying and
paying for the cat jesus christ
maybe f6 um what's your purpose of f6 to
get out of the bishop because if you're
gonna take the bishop then you gotta
take it you gotta take the bishop now
yeah chaos i saw this meme a while ago
like um when somebody that's born like
before 2000 was like would go to buy
alcohol and like they wouldn't really
take check their id's as much they were
just yeah it's before 2000 there already
21 above
felt slightly sad there's a one
yeah
basically oh my god
okay i like this but i think the the
healthiest one is just getting rid of
the bishop i feel like like you had the
purpose of coming over here so let's get
rid of this first and then you can do
the queen b6 that chat is loving
now after queen b6 uh white onion went
bishop f3 trying to fight for
some space and some equality but now the
question is can we take this pawn
because if we can take it then you know
that's a free pun
free upcoming dessert
yeah if you go and watch the twitch
stream that i did like literally an hour
ago
i came up with a theme song about eating
ponds
currently i can't remember the melody
which is very sad
but
it was fun
ah there we go ben but now we have our
own team song about doors i think pawns
oh my goodness
yeah well that's the thing white is it
under attack so we might not want to
exchange pieces you are correct but
we're also eating free stuff eating
first stuff
when you go to
america and you go to college you learn
free stuff is always delicious
you eat it you don't say no to it also
yasser is a pawn eater so if you like
yah sir you do it
one of the two
all right so take take kaboom
up all right now what
now the problem is if we took it then
the king would take
oh yeah keep that going good good good
yeah oh my god in america everything is
so expensive
parking is so expensive
yeah
i don't have my own car yet but
i've been driving around with people
enough to know that they really do not
want to pay for parking
yeah queen c1 why not
all right now we're in a situation that
we gotta decide
do we want to make our opponent think we
are gonna do perpetual
yes
we always want to do that
we always always always want to um
mess with our opponent's head
hence this is just on psychology so if
your opponent thinks you're going to do
draw and then you're not actually going
to do draw oh let them think it yeah
queen e3 quincy one and okay now we
don't want to do the perpetual so what
is the actual best move
and yeah k on you're correct uh parking
in new york or chicago is um
equaling tombstone basically but yeah so
i was in chicago a few days ago actually
yesterday
and i was driving around with one of my
college friends of a friend
and yeah with with her we realized we
experienced the parking pain
randy i am sorry but
i mean chess as a i mean i'm playing it
to win i'm not playing it to
smile at you and let you
beat me up
playing it to win so
you don't necessarily need to do evil
laughter when you're doing um
the
perpetual out loud
so
um
not really the bishop is under attack
or you can move this bishop because the
queen is protected currently
fair point but if you could exchange the
queens and win material i would strongly
recommend that too
yeah because that's the kind of that's
the that's the concept of converting
your advantage which is also a
thermodynamic concept
of conserving the energy conservation
but anyways um so that's the thing as
long as you keep your advantage and you
don't blunder stuff you can exchange
your advantage you can have a really
nice attack then you can win some
material out of it and then you can give
up that material to form a nice attack
and the circle goes on and on and on so
take take check come back check come
down and
they repeated one more time i'm assuming
that they were also because this is
around move 30 so i'm assuming that
because a lot of the high class
tournaments you get extra 30 minutes 40
minutes 50 minutes depending on the
tournament you get some time after the
30th move sometimes it's 48 move you are
kind of like waiting for that um time
cut off again i might be wrong on this
but he if if they were um
if mcshane was
in a
time crunch if he had like two minutes
with every one move you gain 30 seconds
so if you can just throw in two checks
that's one one whole minute so not the
worst idea
yeah
so
finally queen f4 now the idea is i next
i'm gonna get this truck coming this is
a beautiful night here i can also want
to do you know knight sea ones and make
sure to eat some of your other material
or i'm gonna bring my rook you can't
really stop both of them so white went
queen h2 and kaboom queen f3
rook f1
check
king up all right i'm gonna take a small
pause now blocks to move what do we do
we're almost done with this game black
has a really gorgeous advantage
we gotta do is keep hunting down the
king
exactly thank you yeah keon you're so
funny yes kaboom blasting the sitting
ducks yep we are actually about to make
the road a duck roast
roast dog i don't know we're going to
serve the dogs basically
work the years yeah that definitely
should do it too
you so you gotta the the thing is you're
either going to have to bring the rook
or bring the knight to your queen alone
is not enough so either one is good
if you bring rook nate that's good too
whoa not that if you bring it oh my
goodness if you bring a rookie that's
good too you want to go down here if
king goes to g1 you'll still go over
here your knight is defending it if you
move the queen the queen g2 is coming up
queen g4 is like super lost
uh if you wanted to deny d2 as well that
works so if you move it kaboom check if
you move it another check
now knight f3 is coming up again rook
the eighth so actually um i believe
after queen f3 oronian just resigned
uh sorry actually here orion just
resigned and yeah black fights very
beautifully from start to end
and
at this time our onion was actually
world number two
so
yeah mike shane had a lot of fun with
this hopefully he celebrated properly
after this
and
that is the game that i really wanted to
show you guys today and hopefully you
enjoyed it i did
it's always kind of interesting to see
super grandmasters
not score full points or even any points
against low rated kind of gives you hope
so yeah
um
right right so yeah make sure to
go take a tiny break and join us on
twitch we're gonna do our switch to
twitch segments to analyze your games on
lycha so if you have games please have
them ready and meet us there in about 10
minutes
thank you everybody and see you
hopefully shortly
[Music]
you